Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lobs, and
today I'm joined by Amy Baldwin. She's co-host of
the Shameless Sex podcast. She's also a sex educator
and sex and relationship coach, and she's the author
together with April Lampert, who, by the way, is
the other co-host of the Shameless Sex podcast of
uh Shameless. Choose your own pleasure path to unlock
the sex life you've been waiting for. So, Amy,
welcome to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you. Yeah, that book title is um a
mouthful. 11 of our criticisms is that if we
were to write a second book or if we
could redo it, we would not have such a
longing a long-running title because we don't even remember
it. It's a good job.
Yeah, sure. So, look, I, I've been following your
podcast for a while now, and, uh, particularly because
I've also been doing this series on my own
podcast, which I titled Humanizing Sex Workers, and just
a couple of months ago you had Nina Hartley
on the show. I thought, oh, OK, so now
maybe it's the time to invite them on the
show, so you're here with me today. Um. So
let me ask you this, what do you think
are some of the biggest obstacles in our societies
when it comes to talking about sex? I mean,
why do you think it is such a taboo
topic, and how do you think we should approach
sex in our societies?
Yeah, um, so, well, I, I'm not an expert
in, in religion, uh, in general, and I'd say
that a lot of what we think and believe,
uh, about the, the world in, in, in general,
not just about sex, has to do with, um,
with religious values, religious old religious scripture, and how
it's been indoctrined and woven into culture, even if
you're not a religious person, you don't even realize
it. Um, I, I certainly don't. Uh, AND, uh,
and so the idea is that, you know, sex
is shameful, that it's not something that you're supposed
to do until you're married, and it's only for
procreation, you know, all the things that you may
not actually believe, but still it still somehow affects
you, um, and it affects the culture, and so
obviously, if Having sex outside of marriage, you know,
outside of something that is, um, just for having
children, if that is something you're not supposed to
do, or, or is, you know, if anything outside
of that is taboo, then just talking about sex
is going to be taboo as well. It's going
to be hard. Most people are not trained, educated.
Um, NOR is it modeled, you know, the conversations
about, or, you know, the how-tos of how to
talk about sex, uh, openly, lovingly, honestly, uh, it's
like, I, you know, we generally didn't see our
parents doing this, and, and also it's sex, right?
So there's this idea that parents don't talk to
their kids about sex, right? You don't, you know,
or parents don't show their kids in some way,
shape or. Form that they too are sexual beings
and I'm not saying your parents have to have
sex in front of you, but there's a lot
of parents that will, you know, won't make out
with each other in front of their children because
it's too much, it's too graphic. Instead, I think
that would be a really beautiful thing for young
people to see like, oh, this is what deep
connection, romance, passion, love can look like even in
a marriage. So there's a lot of, uh, factors
going, going on, uh, out and also, oh, porn,
let's throw that one in there too. Um, PORN,
it's a little bit backwards in that. Uh, PORN
is clearly showing sex, but there's the stigma around
watching porn. A lot of porn is too sensationalize,
is created just for shock value or for very
specific viewers. Um, IT'S not showing actual realistic sex.
It's not showing the conversations, the negotiation. You know,
boundaries, all the things that are really important for
healthy, pleasurable sexual experiences with other people. Um, SO,
yeah, it's a, it's a hard game. Like I,
I, I, and I for sure am a wounded
healer. I'm someone who got into this field, uh,
the field of human sexuality at a younger age.
I, I started working in this field, like, meaning,
um, on the education path when I was 18,
I'm 41 now, um, I, because I didn't understand
any of this stuff, like I Had, I had
only had an orgasm from a vibrator. I did,
did not know how to openly talk about sex
with partners. They certainly weren't doing that with me,
and I was really curious, so I was like,
well, if I'm going to go to school for
10 amount of years, I might as well go
to school for something I genuinely want to learn
about, and that was sexuality.
And why do you think that actually, since you
mentioned partners, why do you think that people have
so much difficulty open up even with their own
romantic and or sexual partners about sex, about their
preferences in bed, about even asking their partners what
they what they prefer, what they might be doing
wrong and things like that. I mean, why do
people have so much difficulty having those kinds of
conversations?
Well, isn't it interesting when you think about people
having sex, right? So if I have sex with
my partner, my partner has a, has a penis,
he's, he's a man with a penis. I have
sex with him, um, so we say we have
penetrative sex, and he's inside of me, which to
me is a pretty invasive, intimate, vulnerable thing. So
that, and so a lot of people when having
sex or doing something like that. But then talking
about sex is the thing that's the scary part,
right? I mean, sure, sex itself is, can be
scared, very scary for a lot of people and,
and edgy and vulnerable, but it, but for a
lot of people, it's actually the actual communication that
is, is the trickier, scarier part, and I just
think that's so interesting to consider. It's a little
bit backwards, and I, and I sometimes I highlight
this when I work with clients who are really
scared to talk about sex. Like, do you ever
look at your from this outside perspective, like this
macro view and kind of laugh about this, not
that you're like ha ha, funny, ridiculous, because you're
not, you're not alone at all, but do you
ever look at it like, wow, I'm, I'm comfortable
having this person fuck me, but I can't talk
to them about what I want in the bedroom.
Um, AND that is, there's nothing wrong with you
for that. That is just, again, You're not being
taught how to do that, and, and even outside
of sex, we're not being taught how to just
talk to people in real deep, vulnerable, loving ways.
We don't, we get, I don't know about you're
in Portugal, right? I don't know about Portugal, but
in the US, you know, in high school, In
the public school system we take communications classes to
be to learn to be public speakers for the
most part, not to have loving everyday conversations with
people about hard stuff that would be amazing if
we had that, but then I probably wouldn't have
a job. So, but you know, so again, like
if you, if it wasn't modeled for you. By
your primary caregivers, um, you probably grew up not
having a ton of skills, unless you got really
lucky where you got into a partnership or a
friend circle with a bunch of people who were
really open to talking about sex and beyond, you
know, other things that we'll, we'll say are more
like taboo or challenging conversations, or just vulnerable conversations.
Yeah, and the interesting thing as well is in
my first question, I mean, you were talking at
a certain point about religious people because of their
approach to sex, and I mean, of course I
agree also that I don't know if most of
it, but at least part of the reason why
sex is a taboo in our societies has to
do with religion and with conservative people and conservative
approaches to sex, but I mean, uh, the other
thing is that those people also many times have
an issue with sex education at school, right? So
I mean, if people were to not get any
sex education at School, if they are not supposed
to talk with their parents at home about it
and if they are not educated or trained to
have this kind of deep conversations with their partners
about sex, I mean, what can people do? I
mean, is the only option available learning through porn
then, or I mean what can people do?
Seriously, yeah, well, seriously, and when you, when you
look at it from that perspective. Right, it, it
kind of seems like, you know, if we're not
supposed to do these things, we're not having the
conversations, then it, it really, it to me it
looks like, OK, so sex really is about just
like making babies or like some sort of like,
you know, maintenance patriarch archical, what whatever that word
is a little hard for me, but the patriarchy,
you know what I mean, um, so we look
at it from that perspective, right, and, and, but,
but. That's bullshit because a lot of most people
experience or are looking for pleasure in sex, and
sex is a really great way to experience pleasure
and connection. It's a profound way. It's, it's a
life-changing way that can lead to more aliveness in
your body, to more of a feeling, a sense
of feeling at home of um Of belonging, it's
really powerful. So yeah, so when you don't have
those things, you don't have it in school, you
don't have it with your parents, right? You're, you'd
have, you talk to the, you know, your kids
on the, on the playground. I remember the first
time I heard about blowjobs when I was in
6th grade or something. I had no idea what
it was, right? And then like some boy made
a joke about blowjobs and I was like. What
is that? And no one had taught me, so
naturally I'm thinking you're blowing, like you're actually like
blowing some air out of your mouth, and no,
I didn't go and do that later, everyone. I
heard more through the peer group, through the grapevine,
and I did discover porn. Um, THIS was, I'm
41. This is when the internet uses like the
AOL days, so I'm on my parents' computer Googling
like big dick and like huge tits, and I,
but I'm like 13 or something, maybe I'm 12,
and I didn't realize that it saves your search
history. So my parents came to me and they're
like, um, Amy, were you on the computer because
there's all these searches, and I instantly lied out
because I felt shame. I was like, and my
parents were chill. I was not raised raised in
an environment with a lot of shame around sex.
It wasn't religious, but it wasn't shame around, there
wasn't shame around sex. It was like my parents
knew I was going to have sex before marriage.
It wasn't like save yourself for marriage. I grew
up in Santa Cruz, California, we had comprehensive. Of
sex education. So we learned all about things like
STIs, pregnancy, the things you, you know, not to
do, but pleasure was never a part of the
conversation with my parents or in the school system.
You can't talk about pleasure, like, here's how you
have a powerful orgasm, right? Um, SO, so anyways,
so like it would make sense even though my,
though my upbringing was progressive. That my parents discovering
that I was looking at big dick.com where I
saw what a blowjob really was. No, they're not
blowing, um, that I still would have lied and,
and, you know, I went through that shame process
like, oh my God, my parents know I'm a
pervert or a sexual being or I'm interested in
this thing, so I have to lie, um, because
I wasn't getting the information about pleasure. So that's
my long-winded answer of. The ways people go and
learn about this, yeah, but we have the internet,
we go and watch porn. Porn is wonderful for
entertainment and arousal. It is not the best unless
it's educational porn, like what Erica Lust does. Erica
Lust is amazing, um, educational porn where it's real
bodies who are really experiencing pleasure, and they're getting
paid well, right? Um, BUT most porn is not
there to teach you how to do threesomes or
how to do anal. It is doing things really
quickly, not showing you the hard, tricky stuff that,
you know, especially the conversations, and that's how people
are learning. Then they go and do it, and
then like say anal sex, for example, then they
go and do it and they're like, I never
want to do that, do that again. That felt
terrible because they did it the way they saw
in porn, which is like slamming in. Don't even
use lube, everyone. Uber lube, game changer, use Uber
lube every time you have anal, especially, but for
all sex. Um, AND then, but luckily now we
do have, um, educational platforms, right? I said Erica
Lust. There's also other educational platforms like, you know,
podcasts like yours, like mine, right, where we can
learn, um, and a lot of people are visual
learners. So then there's like the video form. There's
educated is great. They have a whole platform with
all kinds of educational videos that you can watch.
Um, SO, but people really have to seek that
out, right? They have to like know about that
and go seek that out on their own. So
it is available, but most people, unfortunately, are using
porn as their educator. And that's why, again, another
reason why I have a job cause I'm here
to try to fix all the bullshit that you've
learned in porn that's not accurate.
But, but you know what, it's kind of funny
because in my own personal history, I mean, actually
I learned proper things about sex from porn stars
because what happened was that back in 2000, I
want to say 2007, it might have. In 2006,
I'm not sure, but Nina Hartley released her book
Nina Hartley's Guide to Total Sex, and so I
mean it was basically a porn star educating people
on sex, and then she also has that series
from the 2000s which is basically a video series
of the book. But it's porn, but sex education
at the same time. So I mean, I just,
I'm just saying that if you look into the
proper sources, uh, people who are porn stars can
also teach you proper sex,
and it's people who are porn stars that Care,
right? They care about, about offering the world, a
different message beyond just sensationalism, beyond just entertainment. Nina
Hartley certainly is that good for you for discovering
that right early on in the game because not
all porn stars care about that, right? They're just,
it's a, it's a job, um, for, for Nina
Hartley, she is an activist. She's an educator, and
so she, she really took a different angle, um,
and she's not the only one that does it.
There's, there's other porn stars. I just forgot the
name. I totally know her. She's been on our
podcast. But anyways, um, I, it'll come to me
at some point. She's amazing. There's other porn stars
who do this, and I think it's really important
work. Porn stars are amazing humans. They are sexual
athletes. They're really skilled at what they do. People
discredit their careers, and they like think that it's
not a, what a skill to go and have
one, sex on camera, two sex on camera for
extended periods of time. Um, 3, like, but they're
very in tune often, not all of them, right?
But like, hopefully with really good ethical porn, they're
very in tune with their bodies, with their pleasure,
with, you know, like the whatever, all the angles,
all the things, so, Don't discredit that, but you,
but like I would just wouldn't rely on like,
you know, going to Pornhub or whatever to learn
how to do most things related to sex.
000 no, definitely not Pornhub, no, nor any of
those websites. I mean you can do that for
fun, of course, but not to learn about real
sex, let's say. So, but I, I mean, when
is it that you think people should seek help?
I mean, what are perhaps some of the I
don't know, factors that or, or signs that they
should look into when they're having difficulty in bed
and uh instead of just really trying to figure
out how to solve the issue by themselves, they
should perhaps seek the help of, I don't know,
a sexologist or a psychotherapist or a sex coach
or someone like that. I mean, when is it
that people really need to Uh, ask for help.
Yeah, I think it's when, when you're, when or
if you hit a point, and I think most
people who live a long life will hit this
point, especially in long-term relationships, where you're feeling really
stuck and lost, right? It's like that, that feeling
of like, I can't figure this thing out. I
can't, I like, I know that there's change available.
I hear about it, I've seen it, I want
it, but I just, I can't. I'm trying the
things, or I don't even know what the things
are, so I need someone to tell me what
the things are, because it's really different for everyone.
Um, SO it's, it's a little bit of like
a, uh, you know, a, a lost, stuck feeling,
at least, you know, when I work with clients,
um, but these days I'm mostly focusing on working
with couples, but I have worked with a lot
of individuals as well, and I still work with
with the individuals within the couples. Um, AND, and
they're usually at a point of like, stuck in
some sort of pattern, loop, a disconnection, or for
individuals, it's like a disconnection with your body, right?
Like maybe an example for an individual would be,
um, like, let's say for a pussy owner, a
common one would be like and it's really hard
to feel your own pleasure. Um, TO feel connected
to your body, and, and, and, and you're trying
the things, you're having sex, and it's just like
is not changing, right? But you want, you have
to also want this, this shift, right? No one
reaches out to a coach or therapist, they don't
want it though, because like that's like the big
leap. Um, OR like a penis owner, right, who,
uh, you're, you know, you can get erections when
you masturbate, but then the minute you're with a
partner, your cock goes soft, and, you know, you
know you can take Viagra and things, but you
really wanna learn for yourself, like, what is this?
What is it about being with people that makes
it hard to be hard? Um, WITHOUT medication. So,
yeah, it's, it's that you're like, I'm, you're kind
of feeling stuck, and then maybe like fed up,
like ready for, for big changes to really live
your life, and I think that's one of the,
the, the blessings, the beauty and the curse of
living this day and age, is we have access
to all this information through social media, YouTube, podcasts,
the TV, you know, all those things to see
what is available, which is great. It's like puts
all these things like, oh my God, I can
have that too. I, if I work towards this,
I can have that too. But the curse is,
you know, we want it all, so, and we
maybe can't necessarily have it all, and another curse
is we see specific ideas of how it should
be, and our variation is different. It's different for
everyone, and so a lot of people are striving
to be just like, That one character, like maybe
some people here or see me and they want
to be more like Amy Baldwin. Sure, you can
maybe learn some things that are Amy Baldwin or
that I do that works for me, that work
for you, but some of the things that work
for me won't work for you or not you.
So, um, yeah, so I, I think that that
is uh something that can really push people and
inspire them to like, to take the leap to
do work because they have access to seeing what
is available.
Yeah, by the way, how can people learn about
their sexual preferences? Of course, because people have to
explore, to do some exploration, to really learn about
their own sexual preferences, but how can they do
it in a safe And by safe I mean
not only safe physically and sexually but also safe
in terms of feeling that they are not being
judged or they are not being exposed in any
way that will make them feel shame or something
like that and particularly if to learn about one's
sexual preferences they need some, some of it they
need to do it. With a partner and they
might be afraid that, oh, OK, if I ask
my sexual or romantic partner to try this or
try that because I'm not sure if I might
like it or not, maybe it will ruin the
relationship. Maybe they will look down on me, maybe
they will think bad of me, something like that.
Maybe I will feel shame. I mean, what's the
safest or what are the safest ways of doing
that?
Yeah. Uh, I, I think, uh, it, it all
starts with the individual, right? So, uh, we say
this for, for pleasure, we say like, you, you
know, learn your own body and what your body
wants and likes before you go and share your
body with other people, or you expect other people
to understand your body. Um, A lot of people
are, are having sex just assuming someone's going to
understand them, or figure them out, or even teach
them what they like, and that can happen. But
don't rely on that, um, that that could be
a major disappointment. Um, SO this is, there's a
lot of opportunity for you to go learn your
body, everything from the mechanics, right? Like just the
masturbation practice, like what do my genitals or what
does my body like in terms of touch. Once
you have the information, you can share that with
partners when, and when you know that you're more,
you're already a more confident lover because you know
your body, your body isn't a big mystery to
you. I mean, you won't fully ever understand your
body and your body is always changing. Um, BUT,
but yeah, so then you, so then you have
more information to share with people, but the same
goes for your, your like emotional health, your wants,
your needs, desires, not just like how you have
an orgasm or experience physical pleasure. Uh, I was
just talking about this with, um, the, our marketing
director who I'm just gusted on our podcast on
Shameless Sex, the podcast. Um, BECAUSE she is in
the Somatica training right now, which is a sex
and relationship coaching training that is very much about,
um, it's very experiential and very much about, um,
being embodied and having real, real-time experiences, um, that
imprint you, that change you, that, that give you
the experience of I'm safe or I'm sexual or
I experience pleasure. Um, AND so we were just
talking about this, one of the things that they
teach that I think is gold is, um, and
it's, and it also originates from Um, Jack Morin's
work, I think he passed away maybe in the
80s, maybe the 90s, but he wrote the book,
The Erotic Mind and Celeste and Danielle at Somatica
have revamped it to be called Core Desires, and,
and it's discovering within yourself, not like lick here,
touch there, like, what do I want in the
mechanics of like hands, mouths, penises, dildos, sex toys.
Um, IT'S how do I wanna feel as a
sexual being? How do I want to feel when
I'm touching or being touched? Um, AND that, that
cause that feeling is really important and is pretty
consistent throughout your sexual life. So if, and that,
and everyone's feeling is really different. It really speaks
to them, and the fun thing about the feeling
is really fun and interesting and also wacky is
that it stems from your childhood. Um, SO that's
not very sexy, but it comes from how your
primary caregivers did or did not show up from
you. There's some other things too, but like, as
we know, all this stuff stems from childhood, including
sexuality, including interests, desires, fantasies, things you're not into.
Um, AND so when you understand this feeling, and
there's a whole practice on how to learn about
it, go check out Celeste and Danielle's work on
Core Desires, um, when you understand the feeling, like
for me, how I wanna feel is I wanna
feel taken care of. Um, IT doesn't mean my
partner buys me gifts and flowers and like, you
know, has to take me on trips around the
world. It's, I wanna feel energetically and emotionally. ALLY
taken care of and there's a sense of safety
there like my partner's got this. If I scream,
yell, cry, squirt, pee the bed, whatever, they're all
good, right? Like, and that they've got this, and
in fact they're like so into me and turned
on that none of that matters, right? Um, AND
so there's something about that, that if I have
that feeling every time I have sex with someone,
I'm going to have good, if not great sex.
If I have sex without that feeling, I could
still probably have OK sex, but it probably wouldn't
be sustainable, um. So go and learn more about
that. Go and learn more about your fantasies. Listen
to podcast episodes that are about fantasy and give
you a whole bunch of ideas about different fantasies,
the options on the menu. Play with it in
your spank bank while you masturbate and see, is
this my jam? And then you go, and of
course, you need to learn the communication skills to
share this with partners, but then you can share
this with partners and lovers. So it's like the
more research you do, combined with having the experiences,
I mean that's like the masturbating to the fantasy
to see if it's your jam, the more that
will solidify your confidence and your connection to you,
and what works and what doesn't work, and then,
and the last thing I'll say with this one
is, Having partners who can really meet you where
you're at, that don't judge you, that don't say,
oh, that's weird, or that's not normal, or you're
too much of this, or you should be more
of that, and, and, you know, being able to
explore sexually with people who are not those things.
In itself is healing and and will create will
change you in a positive way. So if you're
having sexual experiences with people who are judgy, who
you say, hey, I'd like to try spanking, and
they're like, Oh God, that's like abuse. That's bad.
What's wrong with you? That's not normal. Stop having
sex with those people like, or, or like, or
change the way, change the way you're opening like,
or, or bring that up to them if they're
maybe in your long-term relationship, you can't stop having
sex with them. Let that, sorry, the conversation at
that point needs to be, hey, I'm feeling very
shamed when I share, when I open up with
you about this really vulnerable thing that I'm being
met with a response that that feels really judgy,
and it, and I, my response is I don't
wanna open up. And then maybe you need a
coach, right? Um, BUT look at those things as
teachers, like even those moments, those hard moments of
my partners being a shitty partner right now, they're
judging me as opportunities to share feed loving feedback
with your partner, um, and, and then growth can
happen from there.
Yeah, and if people want to learn more about
sexual fantasies and why most probably the fantasies that
they have are not really that abnormal. It's just
that people don't openly talk about them. Go read
Doctor Justin Le Miller's book, Tell me what you
want and watch my interview with him from uh
October. Last year or November last year, it's a,
it's a really fascinating thing. So but how should
people go about asking their partners what they want?
I mean, I don't know if it's, for example,
a man who wants to try anal sex with
his female partner or, I mean, Sometimes, and it,
it's kind of funny because I, I'm from the
same generation as you. I mean, I'm a, I'm
a millennial. I'm 35, about to turn 36, so,
but even when I was in college, one thing
that was still very prevalent among uh young men
back then was that there was still lots of
A stigma, let's say associated with a man performing
oral sex on a woman. I mean, even my
colleagues back then, some of them were like, Oh,
I don't do that to my girlfriend. That's disgusting.
I'm not into that, blah blah blah, but
I'll get my dick sucked,
yeah, yeah, exactly. But and They looked at it
as if it was kind of a mesty emasculating,
you know, so, but, but of course, but women,
of course, like that. So I mean, how should
people try to communicate with their partner that they
want or they would like for to, to experiment
with specific kinds of things.
Yeah, and I think when you're the way when
you're talking about this, I'm thinking of like two
different scenarios. One is, one is, um, I'd like
to try something brand new that we've never done
before, and another would could be I'd like to
shift something that we're doing in, you know, in
a different way because it's not really working for
me. Um, WHICH is really hard for people to
hear, especially the latter, because then they get in
their, in their heads, like I'm not good enough,
you know, their worthiness barriers come up and, and
even though we know we're not sexual wizards and
born knowing everything, our systems still wanna pretend like
we do, so, but it's not true. Um, AND
there are ways to, to say, so, to have
those hard conversations that are more loving and gentle,
right? If I'm like, Uh, I don't like the
way you touch my pussy, right? That's gonna automatically
cause a problem. Someone's just gonna be like, well,
I mean, for most people, some people could, could
handle that, um, but, you know, so if we're
speaking to altering something that's already happening, um, so
let's, let's say, let's use the, the, um, the,
or actually let's go with the example that that
you had there with like, Uh, a relationship with
a man and a woman and a man who
doesn't go down on his woman, and she wants
him to go down on her. So let's use
that example, um, and so she's desiring more of
this, but they've been together. Let's say maybe they
did it for 6 months, and she's like, he's
like, he's gone down on me once. It looks
like I've had these clients. He's gone on me
once. It looks like he hates it. He's like
waiting for it to end. He's maybe he's doing
the ABCs. He's just not into it, but I
want this, right, whether I know I've orgasm from
him or not, I want this, so. Well, in
that scenario, this is, this is a harder conversation.
I wouldn't have this conversation during sex when people
are naked, etc. This, you wanna have this conversation
outside of the tricky, vulnerable space, because when we're
naked or, or having sex, maybe you're not naked
when you're having sex, maybe, or right before sex
or during after. People are in their more like
delicate vulnerable space because it, it is, it's sucks,
right? It's edgy, um, have the conversation outside the
bedroom. Maybe you're, you know, in, in when everyone's
in good spirits, you're not in a rush, right?
So maybe you're going for a walk or maybe
you have some time in the morning and you're
going to sit down and have coffee with your
partner, um, and you want to bring this up.
But, but when you bring it up, don't corner
them. Don't be like, hey. Uh, I'm like, I
wanna talk to you about this, this thing with
my pussy that you're not doing, right? Don't do
it that way. Ask them permission first, and this
is very much in our book, um, in Shameless
Sex, the book, we have a whole chapter on
communication and we have Um, an acronym called connected,
and it's a formula with these steps for having
tricky conversations, um, and one of the big steps
there is, um, you wanna get permission first, give,
or you're also giving permission, right? But hey, do
I have permission to open up this really challenging
conversation with you or something that could be triggering?
I wanna, there's Something that's really important to me,
I've been thinking about related to our sex life,
and I'm wondering if now is a good time
to talk about it. Chances are they're gonna say
yes because they're, if they're like, you know, even
if they're busy, they're like super anxious and wanna
talk about it. But if not, if they're, if
they say, no, now is not a good time,
schedule a time. OK, so say they say, yes,
now is a good time. So now, start talking
about the thing, but I would recommend, April calls
this a shit sandwich, but I recommend speaking to
something that really is working to start, that helps
the nervous system. Settle down, feel like everyone's doing
a good job, and make sure it's authentic, right?
So, it could be as simple as like, I'm,
I, I love, I love you, right? Or I
love our relationship, or um I'm just having so
much fun exploring in the bedroom with you, something
like that. And now you're gonna follow it with
the thing that you're asking for, that you're wanting
more of. And I have had, I've, I've I'm
someone that has had orgasms from oral sex in
the past, from someone going down on me. It's
something that I really enjoy, it's something that isn't
happening a lot in our relationship, and I'm really
curious, and I would actually with that one I'd
be, cause I would be curious like as to
the why, but you don't wanna grill the person.
Like I'm really curious if you're open to doing
that more, or if you have any feelings about
it, like why that's not something you're, you're doing
regularly, um, and so you're, so you're bringing curiosity
in there. You're not like making assumptions, you're not
telling the person they're wrong, they're bad, you're saying,
here's me and what I want more of, and
I'm also really curious, like how you feel about
this, and then you start to have the conversation.
So that's kind of like, that's with something that's
already happening. Um, I can stop at that cause
then I have an example for, uh, for something
that, um, you're, that is like a new thing,
that which is a much easier trick.
OK. Uh, LOOK, another question that I have here
is, is there any amount of sex that is
abnormal? I mean, because, OK, we can, we can
go to the two extremes, right? I mean, we
can think about perhaps people having too little sex,
and of course nowadays, for example, we are more
and more aware of the existence of a. Sexual
people, I mean, people who are really not into
sex and they are just part of the normal
human variation. So, I mean, that's perfectly normal, I
think. But then, uh, within people who are sexual,
which is the vast majority of humanity, I mean,
do you think that there's really an X number
of Time that if people are coupled, they should
be having sex a week or a month or
whatever amount of time. I mean, is there a
minimum because, because, or is it more of a
matter of whether both parties are satisfied with the
amount of sex they're having and The number of
times per day, per week, per month, whatever is
not really that important, and, uh, I mean, is
there, and on the other end of the spectrum,
can people be having too much sex? I mean,
is that a thing at all or or
no?
Yeah,
yeah, so with the, so with the former, the
one about how much sex people should be having,
it's really different for everyone. Um, I believe, at
least in the United States, the, the definition, or
one of the definitions of a sexless marriage is
having sex, I think it's under 11 times a
year, and that's interesting to me, but that doesn't
apply to everyone. I know some couples who just
really aren't. Uh, LIKE super sexual beings, they're maybe
still like very loving, affectionate, but actual sex really
isn't just, isn't something that is very interesting to
them or drives them. Um, AND they're not necessarily
asexual, it's just not that important. And so if
you have two people that feel the same way,
then maybe having sex under 11 times a year
is just fine for them. But, you know, what
happens when you're with, you're in a relationship with,
you know, one or more people, you're taking into
account different libidos, right? Different appetites, different interest levels,
desires. It really makes things complicated, but that's relationships.
Um, AND so it really does, it matters what,
what, you know, what I want and what my
partner wants, and then putting those together in a
way where everyone feels like their needs are getting
met. So if my partner wants to have sex
every day, and I'm more like, I only wanna
have sex 3 times a week, I've heard Some
therapists and educators say, then you go with the
lower one or something. I'm more of a fan
of figuring out all of the ways that you
can lean in, not to become the other person,
so I'm not gonna all of a sudden, oh
yeah, now I need to learn to, to like
sex every day because my partner likes that. More
like, OK, my partner wants sex every day. I'm,
I'm more into 3 times a week. First of
all, what does sex mean to me though? Is
sex always involving penetration? Can sex just be oral
sex or, or hand sex or us getting naked
and grinding at each other and making out? Because
if it can, then I'm I'm actually more open
to having sex every day as long as this
is just an example, right, but I think that's
a common one is that that we start to
assume all, all any sort of like erotic touch
leads to penetration. It has to lead to penetration
and that penetration is the is sex. Um, WHICH
can be a lot of pressure for people, um,
and so, so yeah, it's really a like leaning
in. How far can you lean into your partner's
needs? How far can they lean into your needs
without anyone losing themselves entirely? Uh, I think that
is, is the goal for, for figuring out how
often you should be having sex, but also know
that this will change, you know, if you're in
a long-term relationship for You know, 1020, 30 years,
and you're, you know, we age and your hormones
change, or you go through different traumatic experiences in
life, sex, desire for sex changes. Um, YOU know,
I'm someone, I'm now, um, thank you, uh, thank
you to Swan Medical in Los Gatos, California. Um,
I am, uh, on test or on testosterone. I'm
doing hormone replacement therapy at age 41. Because in
my mid to late 30s, I started to notice
my libido naturally was just kind of dropping. I,
I'm a sex educator, I know all the tools,
and it shifted, and so I started working with
them, um, and, but, you know, and, and that
made it so, but I did wasn't doing it
to make my partner happy. I wasn't doing it
to make sure I was able to have sex
as much as they wanted. I was doing it
because I wanted to feel more alive. Um, SO
I highly recommend that if you're in the United
States, go check out swan MD.com. There, it's a
game changer. Um, BUT anyway, so that's that one
about how much the too muchness. The only reason
why I would say it's possible to have too
much sex would be if you're starting to notice
that it is affecting your everyday life, meaning like,
and, and as you probably know, the jury is
still out on sex addiction within the human sexuality
field. There are people, it's like half the people
don't think sex addiction is real and half the
people do. So I'm not going to tell you
what what is true and what is not, but
if you feel like sex or masturbation is starting
to affect your everyday life, like you're not showing
up for your job, you're losing sleep, you're, you
know, you're feeling like it's, it's harming your health
or your relationships, then maybe you are having too
much sex. It's usually not the case, so, it's
usually not that people having too much sex, it's
usually more like masturbation or porn issue as opposed
to actually the physical act.
Do you think that if the sex drive, if
there's a big discrepancy between the sex drives of
each partner, there are any scenarios where it could
be, it could make sense without hurting the relationship,
of course, particularly in the long term. IF the
partner who has the highest sex drive, it compensates
with, it compensates it with watching porn, I mean,
or can that be harmful for the relationship?
I think they totally could. I, it really depends
on you, uh, as the viewer watching the porn.
It depends on the porn that you're watching, it
depends on how you utilize the porn. Um, SO
like one thing you want to watch out for
is, uh, like the same thing with sex toys,
right, because porn sex toys could go in, in
a similar category of like either a bonus or
replacement. I don't wanna say replacement. I talk about
sex toys though, because a lot of men in
particular. Can feel threatened by sex toys like it's
replacing you. The sex toy can't make at this
point still because I mean, the technology is changing,
but it doesn't make out with you. It doesn't
tell you you're beautiful and I love you. It
doesn't snuggle you. You're not being replaced. It is
just pleasure. It's a bonus, um, but, you know,
if you're starting to use these things as something
to, to satisfy you outside of your relationship, nothing
wrong with that. But if you notice your system
starting to want that more than your relationship, you
know, having sex with your partner. That's something to
look at. That could mean one, you're just not
compatible with your partner. Your partner's not compatible with
you. It's a bad fit. Or two, that you're
starting to use this other thing too much that
you're getting like. Like so accustomed to it that
the that the real thing isn't really landing for
you the way this other porn can be very
intense. It's like the fast lane to pleasure, same
with sex toys. So, I'd say you like watching
porn and using sex toys, you're using these things
in ways that are a bonus that are enhancing
your life, and if you start to notice times
or moments where it doesn't feel like it's doing
that, slow down or don't, or take a break
and reassess the situation.
Yeah, another thing that I've talked about with Dr.
Nicole Brosi on the show a few years ago
when we were talking about the neuroscience of the
neuroscience and psychology of pornography was that at a
certain point I asked her if there could be
an issue if one of the Partners watches porn
and the other doesn't, and she told me that
for example if it's the man watching the porn
and the woman not, then one thing that could
happen, it doesn't necessarily happen but could happen is
that the woman starts feeling a little bit insecure
because they might. Uh, SHE might start asking herself,
oh, if he's, if he's watching porn or if
he's watching so much porn, is it because the,
uh, female performers are more sexier, more beautiful than
I am, or, or it might be because I'm
not as good in bed as they are or
something like that. So do, do you agree with
that?
I, yeah, I, I, I, I do not, and
it's a slippery, it could, can be a slippery
slope. It really, again, it's the responsibility of the
viewer to just, just like with anything when we
eat sugar, right, we need to be careful about
how much sugar we eat and, you know, with
Porn or, you know, sex, drugs, rock and roll,
all of the things, right? There is, there is,
there's an importance around balance and that if we
bombard our systems with too much of something, we
can become really accustomed to it and have a
hard time relating to the outside world without that
thing, you know, becomes like a crutch or an
addiction. Um, BUT it, it is really common for
people to feel insecure about their partner watching porn.
I always remind people like for or even like
working with cam models or, or sex workers, right?
Um, YOU know, I actually think if your partner
is going to go and, and be intimate with
someone else, like say you have some, some non-monogamy
set up where they can go and be intimate
with someone else, maybe it's a hall pass. A
sex worker is a lot. Safer than an everyday
person because they generally are not looking to fall
in love with your partner. So, um, if you
know that it's a, it's a little bit of
a safer bet or a cam model. They're online.
They're not actually physically touching your partner and they
probably aren't looking to date your partner too. And
and
also sexually, a sex worker is safer as well
because they always use condoms and all of that,
right? They're, they're exactly. Everyone thinks this is a
dirt, they're dir. You're like, no, they're actually, they're,
they're more sexually wise and responsible. So, so it's
a, it's a safer bet. But that insecurity of
like, uh, you know, what if that I'm not
hot enough and the porn star is more attractive,
they're not gonna leave you for the porn star
because the porn star is not even trying to
be with your partner in the first place. So
I would get over that whole feeling. But when
you have those insecurities come up again, look at
this as an opportunity. To do a deep dive
into yourself, get curious. Why am I feeling so
insecure that when my partner watches porn, that I'm
not good enough? What is that about? Maybe that's
my own stuff about how I feel about my
body, how I feel about my my, my sexual
performance. Maybe that's something for me to work on.
Now, if your partner is watching porn and not
having sex with you, and you wanna have sex
with your partner, That's a whole another can of
worms, that's a whole another issue, right? Like your
partner, your partner is in fact abandoning you for
porn. That is a relationship issue. Um, BUT just
because your partner is experiencing pleasure and joy, um,
by watching porn and masturbating, and they're still interested
in you, attracted to you, and having sex with
you, that there, there, this shouldn't be a threat
to, to you as a person, but that's how
a lot of people perceive it.
By the way, since you mentioned sex workers, within
this sort of more sexually positive approach that you
have, a sex positive approach that you have, do
you also include sex workers in that? I mean,
what kind of role do you think sex workers
can play in a sexually healthy and positive society?
And I mean, I'm not sure if you identify
as a feminist or if you are into feminism,
but do you think that when it comes to
women being able to express themselves sexually, to be
sexually liberated, that we should also include The possibility
of them being sex workers in debt or not.
If, if they want to 100%, right, it's, it's
our bodies and so it's our right to do
what we want with our bodies as long as
we're not harming other people or taking away consent
from other people. Um, SO I look at my
body as like it's my own research project. I
get to decide what, what I do with it,
again, as long as I'm not harming other people
along the way. Um, AND sex workers, oh, I
actually had this, um, these clients. It was a
couple, and they had both been married before. They're
in their, you know, they're in their maybe late
50s or probably early 60s. I'm really bad at
gauging age, but probably early 60s, and so they
are remarried with each other. And she was in
a sexless, like not sexless, sorry, a terrible marriage
for like 20 or 30 years. It was actually
an arranged marriage for a long time with a
partner who didn't care about her pleasure, and she
was convinced she didn't like sex. She was bad
at sex. I think he even told her like,
you're bad at sex only because she wasn't responding
to his, him just fucking her the way he
wanted to. Um, OF course she wasn't responding well
to that, not wanting to have sex with him
because the sex was not, not considerate. It wasn't
connected. Um, ANYWAYS, so what she did is, is
when she left that marriage, or maybe it was
actually what inspired her to finally leave the marriage,
she hired a male sex worker to teach, have
sex with her, and to teach her about sex
and her own pleasure, and the male sex worker,
one, gave her pleasure in orgasms and told her
she was an amazing lover. And so now she
has these skills and she felt confident to go
out there in the dating world. Now she has
a new husband, and he knows this, and he's
stoked for her because he's like, uh, lucky me.
Like she did, you know, she's super confident. She
learned some skills. She learned that she's a great
lover. She learned, unlearned the bullshit that she was
taught. So sex workers, I think, um, they play
in a very important role in society. Um, WHETHER
it's for people who don't have access to I
mean, sex with someone else, like maybe you're just
not getting laid as much as you want, or
maybe you never have, maybe there's a deficit of
touch in your world, and touch is really important,
and you can pay someone to have sex with
you, and they're benefiting cause they're getting paid, you
know, it's a, they're making a living and you're
benefiting because, you know, well, sex, pleasure and confidence,
um, or if you, it's You know, if, or
if it's something where you are needing, you know,
to have a sexual experience with a sex worker
to heal something. I mean, there's so many purposes
behind sex work, so I think I'm all for
sex workers who are choosing that for themselves, you
know, they, they want this as their Career, whether
it's porn or you're actually having sex with someone
else, well, porn is still actually having sex with
someone else for money, it's just on camera in
a different way, so it's legal. Um, IT'S so
that's so interesting to me, like that's, that that's
that's OK, but if you're actually like handing someone
money to have sex with you, that's any different,
I don't know, whatever.
You know, it's, it's really interesting when you get
to have conversations with sex workers because they tell
you things that you would never imagine were happening.
So for example, since I've been doing this series,
as I mentioned, humanizing sex workers, I've had a
conversation, for example, last November with Olivia Bentley, she's
a high-end escort, and she told me things like
that. For example, it happened to her that a
woman took her own husband to her to for
her to teach him how to have sex improperly.
I mean, because he was really bad in bed,
and then she also she and Alice Little, who
is a NASCAR I love. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
she's awesome. They both told me that sometimes a
family member like a mother, a father, an uncle,
older brother would take, I mean, their son or
their younger brother to a sex worker, prostitute to
for for him to lose his virginity, and before
that happened, he Really, I mean incredibly afraid of
even approaching women, and then they just start becoming
more confident and they're like, oh, OK, sex is
good, sex is great, and it's not, and it's
not something that I should be afraid of or
something like that. And so they really build up
their confidence based on that. And I mean there
are many ways that people Who are really who
never done that, who never interacted even with sex
workers, don't even know happened and have sometimes even
if in an unexpected way, a very positive impact
on people's sexual lives.
So I mean if I, when I first started
having sex in my late teenage years, if I
were to have had sex with a skilled person.
Who knew how to be a great lover, knew
how to work with me and my newness with
my body and sexuality, knew how to make things
really safe, you know, all things like all the,
you know, learn, knew all of the hacks to
be a great lover, um, and then it would
have completely changed my sexual trajectory, meaning I wouldn't
have had all the bullshit, terrible sex that I've
had in my life, you know, I wouldn't have
or the experiences that I had where I didn't
listen to my body and I still pushed through
it, you know, all those things. So I think
we'd be a, a better, a better world if
people's, for, you know, there was like a rites
of passage for everyone to go and have sex
with people or someone, but I mean it'd be
kind of messy, right? Everyone now is thinking of
pedophilia and stuff, so that you just just get
over all of that stuff and, and just think
about like if you as a person, your first
time having sex, it was guaranteed. YOU'RE going to
have sex with someone who was amazing, attentive, attuned,
caring, safe lover, and how that could change your
life, right? And sex workers can be that. I
also know how sex workers, I know sex workers
who some of their sessions, it's just someone crying
in their arms while they're being like pet on
the head and told that they're safe and they're
wonderful and that they're, you know, that they're worthy,
things like that, right? It, it comes, it's not
just about fucking.
No, oh yeah, for sure. I mean, the conversations
I've had on the show and even outside the
show with sex workers, I mean, actually, I don't
have proper data on that, but actually the impression
I have is that the higher end sex worker
you are, the higher end escort you are, the
less sex you have with your clients. I mean,
the more they're willing to pay for just spending
time talking with them. Or just taking them out
on weekends and stuff like that. So I, I
mean they, they get, uh, higher, uh, they, they
get more money for less sex.
So yeah, totally, exactly, and, and, you know, I,
I think if you, if you really break that
down again, connection is a big word that that
stands out here, right? Like sex is a part
of connections. The connection is kind of more like
the umbrella. Uh, OF, of in term for like
something that we're seeking. Connection doesn't have to be
deep conversations or eye gazing, or I love you
or something, but connection can be, you know, just
touch without words to just words without touch, right?
But You know, uh, all humans for the most
part, even the most introverted of humans, um, are
desiring, you know, some sense of, of connection outside
of themselves, um, and, and again, sex is a
really, really wonderful avenue to, to do that, and,
but not everyone has access to that, so enter
sex workers, beautiful profession.
OK, so just one final topic slash question I'd
like to ask you. Uh, WHAT can people do,
particularly if they are in very long term relationships,
I mean, uh, decades-long relationships sometimes, what can they
do to keep sex interesting in the long term?
Because that's one type of complaint that is that
we very commonly hear from people in those kinds
of situations.
Mhm. Um, YEAH, the, the word curiosity is the
first one that, that comes to mind. I think
in long-term relationships, uh, people stop being curious about
each other, and I'm not the only one that
thinks that. In fact, I'm pretty sure this was
inspired very much by, um, not Brene Brown, sorry,
Esther Perel's work, um, and she Talks a lot
about curiosity being gold in relationships, but in long-term
relationships, so it's normal to habituate to your partner,
that's a good thing, right? When we start to
habituate, that means we feel safer, like, oh, I
get you, I understand you, I know you well,
so I can relax more, and that safety is
really important for us to be able to be
connected, but it doesn't necessarily, in at least in
long term, it doesn't fuel hotness, desire, newness, things
like that. Um, AND so curiosity is something that
does fuel those things. So, fuel, not fuel, but
fuel. Um, AND so what I would suggest is
in long-term relationships, instead of waking up every day
like, hey, partner, whom I've been with for 20
years, I know you really well, and I know
how to, you know, talk to you, pleasure you,
instead, ask yourself each day, who is my partner
today? Like, like how can I get really curious
about who my partner is today and, and knowing,
knowing that, just like I was talking about perimenopause
and aging. You know, we are always changing every
day, every moment, we are, you, you know, a
new variation of ourselves. Maybe we're not changing drastically,
but, you know, this includes our hopes, dreams, fears,
desires, needs, all of those things. Um, AND it's
not like every day you have to be like,
hey partner, tell me about what you need today,
now, or like, what are your fantasies now? What
about now? What about now, right? Not like that,
but But people start taking their partners for granted,
and that is a really common thing, like, we
have a routine, we got a whole thing going,
and now I feel like I don't need to
put in the effort to constantly discovering you, um,
and And, and part of that is also constant
being, you have to be open to being constantly
discovered, right? Um, SO it goes, it goes both
ways, but um, I, I just really, it's like
a reframing of how you view being in a
relationship and how you view your partner. Um, AND,
and then there's all the tools, right? Like you
can create a yes, no, maybe list of different
interests that you might wanna try, listen to podcasts
like Shameless Sex or this podcast. Oh, I heard
this thing, I wanna try this. I don't wanna
try that. Right, newness is great, trying the new
things, um, but curiosity has to happen before that,
like, again, I think the connection is kind of
more like the umbrella. Um, THING that we're navigating
towards or off of for sexual engagements, um, you
know, for long-term relationships, I think curiosity is, is
really something that you want to, um, like write
it, you know, write it on a whiteboard, and
then all the other things that go under it
that you wanna try, lick here, touch there, you
know, watch this porn, have the gang bang, don't
have the gang bang, that all comes after being
curious. Um, YOU know, if you're meeting with your
partner once a week, and you're doing sex life
check-ins or just relationship check-ins, first, like, this is,
this is great. You, you could, you could do
this for 5 to 10 minutes, uh, once a
week. Let first share what's working, what's really good
in our relationship right now, then share something that
each of you are wanting more of or want
maybe interested in trying. Um, AND then if you,
if there, you wanna be really edgy, then you
can also share something that is like, maybe isn't,
you know, isn't working, but that could also be
part of what isn't what you wanna do, or
sorry, what you want to try. Um, BUT you're,
you're creating an opportunity for you both to share,
I'd like to try this, or I'd like more
of this. When it's one-sided, like if I'm going
to my partner and I'm, I'm the one that's
sharing, I'd want more or I'd like to try
this. That can be kind of scary for my
partner to receive because then it's one-sided, they're like,
oh God, I'm, I'm the one not doing enough,
and what's scary for me because I'm the one
making the big ass. But when we create a
container, you know, a setup situation where, you know,
we're both going to share what we're wanting more
of, what's not working and what's working, then it,
then it opens up the doors for it to
be, well, safer, um, and for a lot to
happen. Oh, I didn't realize you're wanting me to
go down on you more. I thought that once
a week thing was working really well. Oh yeah,
no, I'm, I'm totally down to do that more.
I will start doing that. Thank you for telling
me, like things like that. You might hear things
you just never thought, but they're so simple, could
completely change your sex and relationships just because you're
not talking about it. So if it's hard to
talk about things, create that container to start doing
that.
Great. So, uh, where can people find your work?
I mean, your podcast, of course, it's on YouTube,
but uh, where, where other places on the internet
and social media and all of that can people
find you?
So we are, we mean April and I, April
is, is not here. She has a big, she
works for one of the biggest sex toy companies
in the world. She's got a big old corporate
girl job, so she's, she's quite busy, but she's
always on shameless sex for the most part. Um,
SO Shameless Sex is the podcast. Uh, WE'VE been
doing this podcast since 2017. We release episodes every
single week, every single Tuesday. We've never missed a
Tuesday. We have, uh, over 500 episodes because we
have a bunch of bonus episodes too. Um, AND
you can find us any, just about anywhere where
you listen to podcasts. Yes, we are. On YouTube.
Um, WE are definitely more popular in the audio
world, but we are, we are popular in the
video. So yes, YouTube, Spotify, iTunes, all the things.
Um, WE'RE also on social media. You can find
us on Instagram at Shameless Sex podcast. I'm on
Instagram. I'm Amy Shameless Sex. Also Facebook, all the
things. I don't think we do X. We're not
big X people. Um, BUT yeah, you can go
and listen and learn. It's not just us doing
the podcast. Yes, we are the hosts, but we
have different guests of every single week. Everything from
how to do anal sex to communication skills to
Um, I don't know, non-monogamy 101, all kinds of,
of stuff, uh, and it's just our favorite topic
that ever. We have the book Shameless Sex. I'm
just gonna call it that because the running title
is so long. The book is not just stuff
in the podcast. It's similar to, I don't know,
this is a millennial thing, but if you ever
read those choose your own adventure books from back
in the day. Where it's a fiction book and
you would, you read it and it'd be like,
if like, do you want the Abominable Snowman to
eat you, go to page 60. Do you want
to save the kid from the Abominable Snowman? Go
to page 80. It's written like that, but it's
nonfiction and it's about how to do sex and
relationships your way. So it's kind of like a
guide or a map instead of a Telling you
the answer to your issues or your inquiries, we
say, what's the outcome that, what outcome do you
want? If you want this outcome, go here, you
want this outcome, go there. So you get to
kind of be your own sex and relationship coach.
You can find on our website, shameless sex.com. Uh,
WE have the printed version. There probably is a
Kindle, yeah, there's definitely a Kindle. And then there's
the audiobook which we read ourselves. It is our
voices because we have deep podcast voices. Um, LET'S
see, what else? We do retreats, uh, generally in
the United States, but we have done them in
Costa Rica and Mexico before. Our upcoming retreats are
sold out, but we are, we'll be releasing 2027
soon. Um, THEY'RE usually for couples, sometimes for just
women, but they're fun, immersive, uh, retreats. They're not
a sex party, unfortunately. There are other retreats for
that, but they're not ours. Uh, AND yeah, that's
pretty much the main things that we've, we focus
on over here in shameless sex world. I'm probably
missing some things, but shameless sex.com, shameless sex podcast,
pretty easy.
Awesome. So this has been really fun. Thank you
so much for coming on the show. I'm, and
if there's any other opportunity in the future to
have another conversation, it would be great.
Thank you so much for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Jr.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stinnik,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.